- [Instructor] We're asked
to move the dot to 7/6
on the number line.
So pause this video.
I can move this dot right over here,
but I encourage you, pause the video,
and put your finger on where 7/6 would be
on the number line.
All right, now let's
work on this together.
So what they're saying is,
is from zero to this
point on the number line
right over there, that gets us to 1/6.
So each of these spaces are a sixth.
So we go zero, 1/6, 2/6,
3/6, 4/6, 5/6,
6/6, 7/6.
Let me make sure I got that.
So each of these are a sixth.
So we have one, two, three,
four, five, six, 7/6.
So that's 7/6 on that number line.
Now they have other ways of
getting at the same idea.
For example, they say
which point is at 9/4
on the number line?
And they ask us to choose one answer,
and we can look at the choices here.
So which choice shows
9/4 on the number line?
Pause this video and see
if you can pick that.
All right, now let's
look at each of these.
So it looks like in choice,
in this first choice,
the space between zero and one
is split into one, two,
three, four equal spaces.
So as we go from zero to this next line,
that's a fourth.
And that seems like it keeps going.
So this is 1/4, 2/4, 3/4, 4/4,
5/4, 6/4, 7/4,
8/4, 9/4 is here.
That's what we're looking for.
But the dot is not at 9/4.
It's at 10/4, 11/4, it's at 12/4.
So I don't like choice A.
Let's see, choice B.
Let's see what is, let's see,
we have divided the space
between zero and one
into one, two, three,
four, five, six equal spaces.
So each of these are a sixth.
So to go from zero to one,
you've already gone 6/6,
and then 7/6, 8/6, 9/6.
So this is 9/6, not 9/4.
And so let's look at this last choice.
I'm already feeling like it
should be the answer, but.
We can see that the spaces are the same
as in our first choice,
so these are each fourths.
Once again I know that because the space
between zero and one or
any two whole numbers
is divided into four equal spaces.
So to go from zero to one, you go 4/4,
and then 5/4, 6/4,
7/4, 8/4, and 9/4.
So choice C is definitely looking good.
Let's do one more example.
So here they say, what fraction is located
at Point A on the number line?
Pause this video and see
if you can answer that.
All right.
So between the whole numbers,
how many spaces, equal spaces, do we have?
It looks like we have one, two, three,
four, five, six equal spaces.
So things are divided into sixths.
So 1/6, 2/6, 3/6,
4/6, 5/6, 6/6,
which is equal to one,
and then 7/6.
So this is seven over six, just like that,
and we are done.